[Applause]
Friday
happy Friday and when it's Friday you
know what that means I'm already half in
the bag
let's welcome tonight's guest she's so
Southern she majored in the Dukes of
Hazard co-host of the bottom line on Fox
Business Dagan McDowell
liberals would love to put this clay in
the Kiln co-host of the clay Travis and
Buck Sexton show good hey Travis
all right
he's sharper than a razor and styles his
hair with a taser comedian David Angelo
she's like a mannequin pale and
sometimes her arms fall off
but this is your tributor cat Tim
all right now before we get to some new
stories let's do this
[Music]
it's leftovers where I read the jokes we
didn't use this week and as always it's
my first time reading these so if they
suck will light a stick of dynamite and
put it in Joe Mackey's lunch
I thought we're gonna stay up his ass
funnier
should have gone with my instincts here
we go
Joe Biden finally went to the
devastation in Hawaii this week he was
he was reluctant to go until he found
out there's a beach
I know he's an awful man this week Vivek
ramaswamy joined RFK Jr
as current presidential candidates
who've been spotted in public shirtless
all I can say is thank God she's not
running
terrible
oh clap away if you will
Pennsylvania Senator John Federman
looked unrecognizable in a recent selfie
which is an improvement
[Laughter]
Kamala Harris is trying to get another
reshape of her Public Image in the
run-up to 2024. in order to improve her
opinion polls she's changing her name to
hepatitis C
[Laughter]
due to salmonella outbreak the CDC is
advised against kissing or snuggling
Turtles
and this is bad news for some
[Laughter]
yeah
they're still assessing the damage
caused by the earthquake that hit
Southern California this week yesterday
in fact they discovered deep cracks and
fissures in four of the Kardashians
uh Tempo woman is there any other kind
a Tampa woman has fulfilled her
childhood dream of becoming a stripper
just like her mother
we're still trying to track down her dad
for comment
oh wow
like it's our fault that she chose that
lifestyle
a family farm in the UK is begging
tourists to stop posing for naked
pictures in their sunflower field
they're asking everybody to keep their
clothes on and that includes the cows
seriously oh you're awful you're awful
awful stop well the number of
transgender surgeries performed each
year has tripled across the U.S experts
say they haven't seen this many men lose
their balls since the Royal weddings
[Applause]
the new IKEA store just opened in
downtown San Francisco because if
there's one thing thousands of homeless
drug addicts need it's Furniture that's
hard to assemble
this week in Chicago the heat index hit
120 degrees making it the hottest day in
a decade in response law enforcement is
now telling residents to handle their
illegal guns with an oven mitt
earlier this week stock photo somebody
had a stock photo of a gun and an oven
mitt you never thought you'd use that
one
the guy who's had that picture taken
says how come we're not selling these
just wait gutfeld's gonna make a joke
earlier this week five people were
arrested for unruly Behavior at a
Nickelback concert apparently yeah they
were singing Nickelback songs
ah so unfair
according to a new study New Jersey has
been ranked
the worst state to drive in traffic is
so bad drivers report three hour wait
times to give each other the finger
the Spanish soccer president there's a
there's a Spanish soccer Prince
president
he's under Fire for surprising the team
captain by kissing her on the lips
the only saving grace is that he wasn't
allowed to use his hands
Tucker right you can't use your hands
really Master dating is going on dates
by yourself it's apparently the latest
craze among the terminally lonely
ah you get used to it it said one man
I never
unbelievable went really slow so they
can catch up all right now to the news
it's the shot heard or rather seen
around the world last night in Georgia
45 was arrested and his mug shot was
released
look at that after So Much Hunter
coverage it's nice to see a newsmaker
photographed in pants
but you got to give the man credit that
a look you won't forget and it seems to
be saying oh you are so when I'm out of
here trust me
[Applause]
I gotta say I feel the same way
I mean the media can laugh but you get
the sense that once again they went too
far
Trump returned to Twitter now asked for
the first time since January 8 2021 he
reposted his own mug shot with the
caption election interference Never
Surrender and he urged supporters to
visit his website who didn't see that
coming his campaign is already seizing
on the moment like a seagull and a bag
of Funyuns they're fundraising
they're fundraising with a lovely new
collection of short and long sleeved
shirts coffee mugs bumper stickers even
beer koozies
Koozies and unlike kilmead's last book
They're settlement like hotcakes
but what's the media care about besides
gloating over Trump getting
fingerprinted his self-reported height
and weight
at six foot three 215 pounds no full
disclosure though at least 10 pounds of
that was uh Hairspray
but that means he lost more than 25
pounds since his last presidential
physical in 2020 and for the mainstream
media that's where the investigative
journalism begins and ends
his weight is listed
175.
215. 63 215 people pointed out as the
exact dimensions of Lamar Jackson the
quarterback for the Baltimore Ravens
their resemblance is what if he fasted
there's no way and Mark Meadows had to
also self-report his right way he he
clocked in at 2 40. honestly Trump is 25
doesn't matter
[Music]
how's that for a blind spot look at them
look at them they arrest the president
for the first time in history and
instead of wondering what that's going
to do to this country or the voters or
the world
they Riff on everyone's weight who do
they think they are me
[Laughter]
that was funny David
um
you know you look at the media and they
weigh the respond to it and of course
they're they're gleeful but it seems to
me that they must not know Trump he
always gets the last laugh I think
something big is coming yeah well I mean
who knows what the case I guess everyone
doesn't seem to think it's that strong
of a case in Georgia
um the photo it's kind of bringing
everyone together because liberals love
it yeah and Trump people love it they
all see it's like the Rorschach test of
like you know whether you so they're all
on board Trump is interesting though
because he is I've said this before he's
like the only punk rock person left in
America yeah you know yeah he used to
have the Ramones and all these people
now it's just like Taylor Swift and
stuff yeah so people want someone who's
getting in trouble yeah it just happens
to be the president
by the way I like your new Alanis
Morissette look thank you yeah isn't
that ironic
the irony issue didn't know what ironic
meant wasn't that you know what's funny
neither do I yeah I don't either
day again okay I would be a hypocrite to
say they're you know they're obviously
laughing about his weight but that I
only make fun of people's weight when
they call people racist that's my that's
my modus operandi if you haven't noticed
uh
but they have
I think that the weight thing so I was
looking online
and I it dawned on me that President
Trump and the prosecutions and this
persecution of him and his mere
existence he's been doing a public
service for a lot of these people these
left-wing wackos online because they're
like Ronnie and Robbie and Ricky
I think you knew who I'm talking about
um I don't they're ridiculing him
mercilessly and this kind of feedback
loop they get from their followers
that's all they have
because Viagra doesn't work Cialis
nothing the tubular like hump pump that
thing they're not getting anything from
that so their mockery of this man is the
only thing that gives them some get up
and blow yeah sexual pleasure
clay you know what's amazing about this
is that it this guy has never he's been
around for 70 some odd years he was
never arrested in his entirety yeah gets
arrest he becomes president four times
mere coincidence or do you think they
might be out to get him I I got a theory
that they're going to go out to get him
for the first time in 240 years
four-time arrests in five months yeah
and on the wait front yeah
how quickly would all of those people at
MSNBC guys if you make a joke about
Stacy Abrams being fat and by the way
Stacy Abrams is really really fat way
fatter for a Woman by the way than
Donald Trump is for a man right and she
has that photo where she's the only one
not wearing a mask at all those school
kids are sitting around and the data
reflects that if you are fat covid was
more dangerous to you and if you are
five and six years old you basically
don't even know if you get coveted yeah
if you say that Stacy Abrams fat ass
should be the one wearing the mask
because she is an obese adult MSNBC
loses their mind exactly fat shaming
they do yeah but you say right
but Donald Trump says he weighs 215
pounds and they lead their broadcast
with it exactly right so is it fat
shaming not the same for Trump as it
would be for Stacey Haber but it still
blows my mind that like don't they
understand that this is I mean that's
like a that's a joke you make on the
fourth day on the first day this is like
a historical event cat
no
I mean yes
but like everything's a historical event
now yeah that's true nothing's ever
boring anymore no I just want to have a
regular day
but also it's okay I see how they could
have wound up talking about that because
I saw that breaking news Banner below
and they're probably running out of
stuff to break after a certain point yes
because they're saying oh they're
they're just doing probably wall-to-wall
live coverage on this and really the
only news we all knew this was going to
happen the only news is that's what his
mug shot looks like and then you know
all the booking information so you can
only repeat yourself over and over again
before you're desperately desperately
looking for something to add so I could
get that they were excited to be like oh
the weight thing you've got an extra
three minutes out of that that's
probably more what it is than anything I
I gotta say I mean I think the mug shot
is amazing I don't care if you prepared
for it I also think a reckoning is
coming I you don't do this to half of
America and expect that it's going to go
away I mean I I I I I don't know if I
would feel good about this if it was
Hillary or if it was Joe Biden yeah but
from now on I am
I am
I don't like Revenge but now I love it
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else